este hospital está al borde de su
capacidad en su unidad de cuidados
intensivos siete de cada diez camas son
ocupadas por pacientes con coronavirus
en un esfuerzo por bajar la presión 20%
de los enfermos fueron transferidos a
clínicas privadas el problema no es que
no tengamos suficientes recursos sino
que no tenemos suficiente personal para
ayudar no hay suficientes enfermeras
calificadas para trabajar en cuidados
intensivos no hay suficientes asistentes
de enfermería ni tampoco suficientes
doctores el hospital ha traído si en
cuidadores extra para unirse a la
primera línea pero esto sólo alivia una
parte de la carga en el departamento de
bocas del ródano más de 100 personas
están en cuidados intensivos la
situación en bocas del ródano extensa
para darte una idea general sólo tenemos
una docena de camas para pacientes con
kobe y en total sólo 30 de 200 están sin
ocupar
software en la región de provence a más
de 600 personas son tratadas por kobe 19
sólo en la última semana siete mil
ciudadanos dieron positivo